in one corner we have the latest film
from director Neill Blomkamp and the
other corner we have the directorial
debut of alex garland both deal with
artificial intelligence both have a
different champion to explain why one is
great and the other is crap so welcome
to council geeks my name is the thing
away and I am joined by polsce me know
how you doing Paul I'm doing pretty good
Nathaniel I get to talk about science
fiction movies with robots and so 2015
saw the release of two films dealing
with artificial intelligence machines
gaining consciousness sort of thing the
films that I'm talking about our chappie
and ex machina and we have both seen
both of vocus and we both came away with
the exact opposite reactions to them the
short version be he like chappie I like
ex machina being a gentleman yes I shall
allow you to go first okay now before we
do get started I will give a wearing
spoiler warning we're going to be
talking the whole thing so chappie
they're set in this mythological future
where they've decided to incorporate
robots into police forces and we watch
one get tragically sort of destroyed or
nearly destroyed in the battle and then
we cut to a scientist young nerdy guy
who's been developing this AI program he
steals the robot from the senator that
he's working he didn't get approval to
run this her I was correct meanwhile um
he has a work rivalry with Hugh Jackman
well i have so i should be up front that
i have a massive problem with the Hugh
Jackman sort of subplot in this film oh
good me too but um I think the chappie
rises above that and i still and i think
it was one of the best films on AI
despite this sort of underlying time I'm
afraid I'm gonna forget exactly what
occurs but he's trying to cheese
transporting um this robot chappie I've
seen it more recently so I'll jump in on
the synopsis parkca he he gets kidnapped
by a couple of basically just street
thugs who know that he works for the
company that runs the police robots and
they think that he will
have some way to remotely deactivate
them he doesn't I mean that's a very
obvious security measure that but they
don't know he can't do that so they
kidnap him when he's transporting the
body of what will become chappie out so
suddenly they have him and they have
this robot that he that he loads this
software in right basically we watch
chappies development and the scientist
gets basically booted out and the two
sort of surrogate parents that end up
taking up taking up chappies sort of
raising decide to use them for their own
purposes developmentally chappie doesn't
really understand what he's doing he
just wants to make people happy and he's
still learning about who he is but he
does eventually go on these um sort of
crime sprees with them so what worked
for me in this film is that I believe
the chaffee was fantastically miss sold
to the public okay and i believe the
public went into chappie expecting
Robocop and the movie does not deliver
on that at all no right no and so if
that's what your expectations are I
think you're going to be horribly
disappointed in this film chappie is
actually a film about growing up so for
me chappie was asking a number of
questions and some of those questions
were what does it mean to be a man
mm-hmm what does it mean to be a father
what is fatherhood what is entailed with
fatherhood and then I think he was
making some other statements about
things like you don't get to choose your
parents right this is the film i was
watching right now it was a film about a
young boy growing up and trying to
figure out who he is and to people who
never expected to be parents which by
the way is the perfect story for people
trying to raise a kid right trying to
figure out who they are in relationship
to this essentially child who's also a
weapon and watching these sort of
conflicting and often at odds sort of
relationship grow out but I believe that
there is real love in this relationship
I think that they truly do
care about chappy there's a scene where
chappy is learning how to fire a gun
right and he's doing it wrong he's like
however well he's doing it wrong
according to ninja and he totally shows
them how to walk right he's like you
gotta walk like this right and so white
white each a robot that right why bother
right if you're if you're just going to
use this thing as a weapon to take out
like a Brinks truck who cares that's the
reason he does is because he cares about
chappy right he doesn't want him to look
ridiculous right he wants him to look
like a man it is his form of parenting
and is his way of sort of showing chappy
that this is how you have to be in this
world the world is cruel world is harsh
right and people aren't going to respect
you if you look like an idiot I was like
that is maybe one of the best films i've
seen in terms of watching someone grow
up in the course of the film and
watching a young couple rush you know
sort of wrestle with how do we raise
this boy so here's why you're wrong i
absolutely agree with you with what is
trying to do i completely disagree with
you that it succeeded now hit now credit
where credit's due yep I like chappie
himself as a character he is very well
realized he's very well played he's very
well portrayed he's very sympathetic he
is a great character I like Deon who is
the programmer I don't particularly like
the two gangsters but you're not
necessarily supposed to so I'll kind of
go to passive ass ultimately I have to
lay the failure of this film on the feet
of neill blomkamp the man has the
subtlety of a sledgehammer to the face
and I was with this movie I think I
finally checked out and just flipped and
I'm like I and I kind of turned against
the movie I think probably the fourth
time that you on d the girl the woman
gangster is screaming at ninja he's a
child he's a child Neal I got it
I got it already I got it way back when
Dion first loaded the AI program in and
said he will be like a child but learn
faster I got it then but then to have
chappy call her mommy and him daddy and
have people screaming over and over he's
Italian these a child is it stop I got
it now if I'm to make a comparison to a
movie that is also not so but works the
original Planet of the Apes okay that
last image of that film sure hits you in
the gut and it hits you hard but it hits
you in the gut once this movie kept
beating me up with its message and its
metaphor over and over and over again
until I resented it now I won't dwell
too long on this because you yourself
already acknowledged as a problem but
neill blomkamp also does not know how to
do villains who aren't cartoons chappie
has good points I can't call it a good
movie so I I think that the the clanging
that you're hearing in the film right
Yeah Yeah right which is that returning
is that if this was a drama right and it
was a drama about a young couple like
that are drug dealers okay and the dad
is trying to incorporate the Sun into
the business right that we would see
these fights from the couple's
perspective right that we would we would
we would have these moments where the
wife is unhappy with the fact that the
father's trying to incorporate the child
into the business right as a runner or
something doesn't really matter right
and we would see it it would be a
reoccurring theme and it probably would
grow in volume and pitch through the
course of the film as the mother finally
has to you know take more and greater
action to keep her son from being
involved in this business I don't fault
him for his lack of salty I do fault him
for his inability to write melons and to
have a subplot that I care about at all
yeah but I mean just sort of coming back
to what you're saying look I don't have
a problem with the plot progression I
just have a problem with that he doesn't
trust his audience enough to get what
he's on about to just let it be so muy
on from chappie we have X Maki
yes which was the directorial debut of
alex garland and what the film is is a
very strict down film there's basically
only four people in the cast you've got
this coder Caleb who basically kind of
just wins a like a contest sort of thing
within his company I mean his company is
is effectively Google they can't call it
google but it's google it's a company
that has a search engine that ninety
percent of the world searches are done
on this on this engine and it was
created by Nathan who's played by Oscar
Isaac um now caleb is flown out to his
ridiculous a state like massive
monstrous amount of land with this weird
little building in the middle of it that
has a little bit above ground but is
mostly underground tech laboratories yes
so nathan has Caleb come over and Nathan
tells him straight up exactly why he's
there he says I have created something
that I think might be artificial
intelligence and I want you to test it i
want you to interact with it ask it
questions get to know it and help me
figure out if i've actually practice if
I've actually made artificial
intelligence now the artificial
intelligence is named ava um and it it
it is very clearly a machine and yo you
that you can see the robot parts of it
and whatnot but it has a very realistic
skin tone face and then a few hannah on
a few other parts um and also in the
building is Kyoko who is sort of a a
silent Asian character who is who were
told at the outset does not speak
English and Nathan keeps her around
because it means he can talk shop and
trade secrets and doesn't have to worry
about her understanding anything that's
being said but it's basically four
characters in one location yep and it's
very upfront with its intention it's not
hiding the questions of what is
intelligence what is consciousness what
is it to be human behind the veneer of
something else because most films that I
can think of that our science fiction
films at least that deal with these
sorts of questions things like Blade
Runner ghost in the shell
AI or chappy they these questions are
there and they are important but they're
there they're behind something else
they're behind the new are aspects of
Blade Runner there behind the the anime
action of ghost in the shell so there's
something else that this just straight
up this is what it is this is all we're
dealing with so I kind of like that
audacity um I think the performances are
phenomenal i think ava is really well
portrayed and well realised visually i
believe she is played very well there's
basically sort of two moments that
encapsulate why i think this movie
tackles what it does so intelligently i
mean the first is we get a reveal that
Kyoko is in fact a machine herself but
she is completely skinned and she had
been passing for human for the movie up
to this point and this isn't part of the
climax is about the tail end of Act two
now what happens immediately after that
scene is kaleb going in a mirror pulling
at his own skin and then taking a razor
and cutting a gash and literally digging
through his skin looking for circuitry
looking for wires looking for machinery
which first of all is a really unnerving
seen unto itself but i think is a
brilliant placement after we've implied
that machines can totally pass for human
that it immediately gives us a scene
that makes it but he is not he is a
human so don't even start to wonder so
that that question because if they
hadn't done that then that question is
he going to turn out to be machine would
have been in the back of my head
throughout the whole climax I would have
been slightly detachment what was going
on I wouldn't have you know just gone
with it the level that he needed to and
then a little bit later on we find out
that well first of all we we've been
seeing Ava through Caleb's eyes and his
interaction and she is really bonding
with him and she is scared she's scared
Nathan she's scared of what's gonna
happen to her if she doesn't measure up
and through archive security footage we
see that ava is not the first one that
nathan is built he's built quite a few
and they've always been female they've
always been women and in fact
most of the ones prior to Ava were fully
skinned so what we see is archived
footage of him verbally and physically
abusing naked women Caleb sort of tries
one last time to say look I do think she
is a I I do believe that you have really
done it in an effort to try and get
Nathan to not take her apart and use her
parts for the next one and nathan says
to her okay you think that she likes you
does she really like you or is she just
really really good at faking it and the
fact that he says that after we've seen
him abusing the machines is really
important because that means we don't
like him and so when he suggests that we
immediately dismiss it and it ultimately
turns out to be the truth she plays
Caleb like a fiddle in order to get what
she wants which is to get out of there
because ultimately at the end of the
film she gets out she kills Nathan she
locks Caleb in a room that he can't get
out of and she leaves and and it kind of
ends on auto on that sort of melancholy
note and it is it is debatable whether
or not she is in fact true artificial
intelligent but I actually don't think
that's necessarily the point of the film
whether or not she is I think that's a
fun debate to have with people after the
fact so here's why you're wrong okay and
so I think that you know I think you're
right you know in a lot of what you said
the acting is terrific the film is
beautiful visually in this beautiful ava
is arresting so why i hated this phone
haha so one i thought the film had major
pacing issues some of some of my
fundamental problems are so let's say we
have this touring test right we have
this testing is it going to prove that
that she's real can you know has nathan
done it and I think what ultimately
happens is that Caleb falls for a pretty
face that flirts with him and and that
she and that this is sort of what
happens to in this film to me is that
once again female sort of artificial
intelligence or female robots
get reduced to sort of a pretty face and
that they're seductive and that they use
their sort of physical presence to sort
of will their way you know through the
world and that's the role of you know
sort of female a eyes in the film
universe you know what is this movie
about that you know and is it like that
is it just that all men can be easily
sort of like that men are fundamentally
bad or flawed or or easily deceived I'm
like I and so I'm asking these I'm
asking questions of the film doesn't
want me to be asking again I get all of
these moments like okay so what would
you do if you could build robots I guess
I would build sexy Fembots and it's like
okay you would build sexy Fembots good
in the film is filled with the sexy vamp
odds hey sandy you know it's it's like
okay so we've done that um she tricks
him through her feminine wiles um which
are real and and and she gets out and
I'm left and I the film ends and I'm
like um okay so here's sort of my
response to some of this stuff in terms
of Pacey I yet I personally wasn't bored
that it is a slower-moving yes so that's
fine we can move on yep um it's I
actually never really absorbed it
particularly in terms of gender politics
now I'm not going to say that gender
politics aren't a part of the film but I
kind of took it purely on it's AI
questions basis now again yo ass girl
may or may not have had an intended
message in terms of the relationship
between men and women now what I would
say hearing what you're saying and
thinking about it um I still like what
the movie does because yes she has
feminine wiles put into her by Nathan so
that's just what she's got yep and being
a machine with a high degree of
intelligence that is learning is going
to use whatever it has to get out and
what it
as his feminine wiles so I i end up
still liking it because the very thing
that was imposed upon her to make her
weak she then turns around and uses as
her means to escape the fact of the
matter for me was that I spent so much
of my time in the film going okay um and
and just not enjoying it and so I think
I was too much in my head and I didn't
find the ending to be satisfying we
don't really read movies differently but
we just take enjoyment from the
different things that's right because
this is a before because we had we had
very opposing opinions on x-men days of
future past and also on age of Ultron so
but I I still enjoy talking the stuff
out of you ok welcome Paul thank you
very much for coming in and taking the
time to try and battle this out so you
know what we'll toss it to you folks
what do you think was the better film or
if you haven't seen both or you haven't
seen either who do you think made the
better argument so see if you can settle
this one for us drop something down with
the comments and let us know what you
think until next time oh you know what
I'm jumping ahead do you have any
projects you want a pimp well I do I'm
the lead writer for rising sun comics
and armadillo justice and I also write
red and green comics with Ryan Delia
frequent guests on council eeks and
thank you very much the thing l for
having me on absolutely thanks for
coming in so thanks so much for joining
us for this one and until next time this
council is a jerk